はじめしゃちょーコロナ陽性反応1週間の
自宅療養
おはようございます
[音楽]
地上測っとかないとですね一応今日で4日
目かなちょうど折り返しの日なんですけど
昨日とかおとといは朝から
ミーティングがあって
オンラインで結構普通に話してたから
早起きだったんすけど今日は会議がないの
でちょっとすいません
はいもう全然
熱ないよね36度4分今日も健康です4
日間日の光を浴びてねもうね結構自宅1
週間隔離生活
濃厚接触になったりしてもしなきゃいけ
ないかなちょっとあの参考までに僕がどう
いう生活してるのかちょっとお見せしたい
と思いますあのね1個思ったのが
意外と暇じゃないだからもっと何もする
ことなくなっちゃうなと思ってたんです
けど最初3日間はまあ撮影だったり編集
だったりとか色々中止になってリスケとか
もあったんで普通にバタバタしてたんです
けど今日は割とのんびりかなちょっとどう
いう感じの1日になるのか
行きましょう
はいえーと12時半起きて30分後にもう
編集を始めますとはいあのお家に
入れるだけでもすごいありがたいですあの
動画編集とかめっちゃ溜まってたり案件と
かも溜まってたんで超編集しましたもうね
人と会うこともないからそんな朝ごはん
食べたりとかなんかシャワー浴びたりとか
もなくもう起きてそのまま作業に入ると
いう感じです動画は12本ぐらい進んだか
な結構やることが溜まってたので
有意義にしてごさせていただきましたよし
今日の印象終わりです
めっちゃ捗ったなんか色々考えることが今
なくて
すごい今日どうしよう
足をこうしようみたいなのかなないんすよ
家にいなきゃいけないからもう予定が何も
ないからなんか無駄なこと考えなくて済む
しめっちゃ仕事に集中できないですよ
なんか知らないですけど
え飯を頼むか
うわ
ピカチュウか
ご飯が待ち時間はスマブラをしてました
ネット対戦で
頑張ってますよっしゃー
よしよしよしよしよしよしよしよし
VIPに戻った
落ちたんすよVIPからよかったこんな俺
でも一緒にゲームしてくれるゲーム配信者
さんがいたので一緒にスマブラしてました
行きます
[音楽]
もう15時だからもう夕方ですね
家から一歩も出てはいけないので
沖配してもらってご飯は届けてもらって
ますでも人の接触することないから大丈夫
なんですよそういう感じでここを4日間
過ごしておりました
タコライスです何でも頼めるからさお家に
いてもなんかあんまり不自由してないん
ですよもともとそんな外出たいタイプでも
ないしサウナいけないのが辛いぐらいです
マジでもうコロナになってからなんか
やっぱ
体の
何免疫が弱ってたのかなとか色々考え
ちゃって1日1食
ダイエット応答端生活2ヶ月ぐらいしてた
んですけどコロナになる前かなはじめしゃ
ちょーの畑のイベント割ぐらいからもう1
日食やめて1回戻してみようと思ってなん
か痩せすぎたってめっちゃ言われてたから
1回ちょっと普通に戻ろうと思って体重
増やそうと思って3色食べたらもう
64kgから67km68kgぐらいかな
ピョンって戻って一応3色がしっかり食べ
てるんですけど食べ過ぎると体重重くなっ
てきたんでちょっとまた1日1食に戻そう
かなっていうので
多分今日1食これとデザートですいただき
ます
はいアニメ見ながら1日1食のタコライス
をしっかりと噛みしめておりますもうでも
昨日までめっちゃ1日3食どころかもう
なんか
ずっとご飯食べたりなんか体に良さそうな
もの食べてたんで今日からちょっと
しっかりと絞っていこうかなって感じです
あ食べ終わりましたね
幸せの関係機うわうまそううまそう
うまそうすぎるうわーおー
[音楽]
これやばあの冗談だけど今日食べたタコ
ライスとこの幸せなパンキングでしたあ
なんか苦しそうですね
はいあの食後の運動さすがに動くかかん
なさすぎてやばいと思ってやってます
間違いないもうちょっと仕事が残ってたん
でやりますあとしょこたんの
Twitterですセクシーだなよし今日
の動画も公開が無事にできてま18時でも
ほぼやることないからこの後遊んでいこう
かなと
思う許容してこうかなと思ったんですけど
もあのー
俺忙しいんすよ
あの自分で忙しいって誰なんですけども
なんかその超忙しいとかじゃないんです
けどもなんかお休みがないっていう意味の
忙しいっていうかなんか1日びっしり超
忙しいというわけじゃなくてなんか毎日
絶対何かしらぴょんぴょんぴょんぴょん
あるからそんな毎日送ってるわけなんです
けども動画のネタ最近ですね動画のネタを
叶える時間がなくてとてもありがたいこと
にテレビのMCのお仕事をいただいたり
YouTube以外のお仕事をいただい
たりして自分の普通の動画作り以外に
すごい頭使ってて日々ネタがない時間が
全くないのが結構現状なんでちょっとこの
休み期間中にてかなんなら今日だな今日今
から
[音楽]
ネタ100個考えますちょっと今日は1日
動画に向き合うわネタのストックあるん
ですけどもすぐできないことだったり実現
味がない現実味がないことが多かったり
するからちょっと身近にできそうなこと
から今後やりたいことまでちょっとネタ
100個考えます
余裕でした多分正直実家に余裕さえあれば
一生ネタ作れると思ってるからはいお金を
数えてみたりだとかあのとりあえずノート
に思ったこと書いてみたりとかネットで
いろんな情報見たりとかなんか過去動画見
てニヤニヤしたりとかなんかね俺ね予定
詰まってたり考えたりすることあると動画
のネタを思い浮かばないんですよまったく
もうゼロ無理
悩み事とか考え事あるとマジで思い浮かば
ないんでこういう何もない時間っていうの
が久々でよかったです1時間経過しても
この真顔
全然いけますもう
集中力の鬼みたいになってましたねもう
考えることが好きというか
結局俺のやりたいことって動画作りなんで
もう本当にこのどういう動画を撮りたいか
などういう動画やろうかなって考えている
時間がめっちゃ
楽しくてあっという間の2時間でした一応
ノートいっぱいにはまとめられたんです
けど
全然100は無理だ30個ぐらい動画の
ためだったらお金を惜しまないから
結構何でも実現可能なんですけどあくまで
実現可能かどうかとか実現するのにどん
だけ時間かかるかとか色々踏まえると結構
考え込んじゃってでも30個よく出たなっ
て感じちょっと着実にやっていければいい
なと思ってますよし
風呂
[音楽]
いいなぁ
[拍手]
[音楽]
2時間お風呂に入ってましたちょっと
なんかサウナに行けないのがめっちゃ辛く
てもうお風呂で擬似サウナみたいな黒に
入ってるアニメ見てもう死ぬほど汗かいて
ぶっ倒れそうになったら外で水分補給して
みたいな擬似サウナ屋さんをお家でやって
たらもう2時間ぐらい経ってもう今22時
ですねあと2時間で今日が終わります
今日久々に始めようってファンクラブが
あるんですけどもこのファンクラブで定期
的に生配信してるんでそれやっていきたい
と思います宣伝させてください始めるのと
いうはじめたちは3Gで入るともう
グループチャットもあのみんなで話せ
LINEみたいなやつがあったりそこで
しか見れないあの僕の画像とか
生配信めっちゃやりますあとリアルで俺に
会って初めの会員ですってあの証拠見せて
くれたら
神対応しますチューします概要欄にあり
ますのでぜひ入ってみてくださいいやマジ
ねちょっとなんでこんな落ち込んでる
かっていうとですね
[音楽]
本当に
本当にここだけの話ですねここだけの話に
できるっていうコメントがたくさん並ん
だらここだけの話するわはい始めのですね
なかなか普段話せないこととかもここでは
話したりしてます楽しかったおやすみ
めっちゃエビ話しちゃったはい22時間
最後寝る前にマスターデュエルやります
はい
えーと環境も変わってすごいランクマッチ
今ならたくさんできるなと思って一生懸命
やってますけどこれ負けましたあーもう
最悪マジふざけ
そんなマジではいあの気づいたら5時間
ぐらい遊戯王やっててあの3時になって
ましたそうねこういう感じで1日が終わり
ましたもう趣味も仕事も色々
楽しみだしてゆっくりできたかなと思って
ます非常に有益な1日でした
パッと3日
[音楽]